at first I didn't believe it either
neither did I wait did I miss the part
where you explained what the hell you
were talking about also narration
sometimes these gods have children with
humans called half-bloods and Baltimore
hates those assholes four of these
children were headed to camp half-blood
that's racist tree top weaponry also
with this insane kind of accuracy at
whatever invisible distance this is why
not just throw multiple tree tops
something's wrong with the scene that I
can't quite put my finger on probably
because it looks vacation as Thalia Lay
Dying her father Zeus found another way
for her to live anything but a tree
anything but a tree OSH also Zeus has
the power to turn his dying daughter
into a tree just not revive her as a
normal living half-blood princess a gift
to ensure no one in camp half-blood
would die the same way so check off
throne in the air through the woods as
potential causes of death all other
causes of death are still in play I'll
show you didn't want to put a protective
barrier around the camp sooner than this
soon as dammit Alexandra Daddario is so
hot she makes my body hurt cliche we
like Stanley Tucci even though he's in
everything so mr. Tucci would you like
to do a sins video we can't be any more
of an asshole than Michael Banyas Pierce
Brosnan said this and they got Rupert
from Buffy the Vampire Slayer to take
over Zeus can play practical jokes like
this but can't save his daughter when
she's fighting monsters
good sportsmanship you recovered air is
stolen chariot that was threes okay what
about the fall turn you own s sucker
somehow Percy's best friend doesn't
remember that Percy didn't do these
things did not talking to you again
why the hell is beside in making the
water ripple after his son walks away
was there some falling-out we didn't
catch in the last movie there's pretty
much no reason to keep this character's
identity under wraps but sure suspense I
guess he's hungry that's why you don't
play the dumbass pronoun game 100% of
the people talking to Percy would have
assumed he meant the Cyclops guy with
the annoying comic relief Grover
provides an entirely new character
that's even worse is exactly what this
movie needed all excuse me
smells like bull all the characters in
this movie were given vague lines of
dialogue so that everyone could
misunderstand them for hilarity or
suspense why are there ready-made
glasses of juicier so that one could
fall over and the filmmakers could make
the point that something huge was coming
how did this mechanical a spool smell
like a regular ass bowl to Tyson a
minute ago great to find his race fight
because this is like playing the old
video game altered beast also wasn't
Percy in the middle of the fire circle
with the bull a minute ago he even drew
his weapon and everything how did he end
up here mechanical a spool is distracted
by normal ass Bowl things there are
clearly people running around the camp
with no fucking purpose why did the bull
dig its horns into the ground when it
could have just stabbed the stopper see
also mechanical bull comes complete with
gardening tools why didn't you just do
this in the first place hell the guy's
fireproof and everything he could have
saved the whole village but decided to
wait until it was dramatic this
motherfucker is stupid
what is he out of fire no while this
camera angle makes it look like Percy
hit a huge wide area to throw this thing
into the bowl and save the day this is
what that looks like on the outside you
couldn't throw a quarter inside this
thing with any accuracy or strength
especially since you're up against a
wall also mechanical bull was created by
the same dumbasses who built the Death
Star everything in this explosion mrs.
Percy Luke carries around plot devices
out in the open for no reason other than
for Percy to see it and figure out what
it is you know prophecy I have a
prophecy movies with vague prophecies
suck ass oh my god yeah they're pretty
spectacular oh you were making an
exclamation and then putting a twist on
it never mind soos just doesn't have the
power to keep his daughter alive even
entry form Luke poison the tree I
figured that out completely when I saw
him carrying around that blue
for no reason got the boy it looked like
the bull completely shattered the
barrier rather than being let in but
sure let's stick to that in accurate
account of the events also it might have
been in Luke's best interest to inform
all the bad guys that he was going to
poison this street and they could have
destroyed camp half-blood but yeah you
really should try and find some obscure
mechanical bull to do the job and come
back down we'll talk some more
assuming else to the same or I could
just tell you this easy-to-remember
prophecy myself and spare you the
possible insanity Oracle storage they
destroyed her honest and vanish Olympian
gods took no more precautions than the
people who buried parallax only one
half-blood child of the three of this
gods can defeat him because reasons
Olympus to preserve or raze and that is
raised with Z as in destroy I asked
Oracle it's perfectly ready to clear up
grammar and spelling issues with the
prophecy but not provide answers as to
what some of it means that or Percy
simply didn't ask you are the only
living half-blood heir of Zeus Hades or
Poseidon prophecy could refer only to
you and because I'm sticking to this
arbitrary rule that haplit has to mean
half human in every context no matter
what we won't even bother to bring up
the Cyclops dude I'm surprised you want
to go along with her on this mr.
undershirt Underwood whatever nothing to
make silly comic relief characters more
hilarious than forgetting people's names
constantly regarding to I guess none of
these guards have ever witnessed
suspicious behavior before I'm not going
out the Cyclops let me guess the
monsters we saw at the beginning of the
movie that killed Zeus his daughter were
Cyclopes and she mistrust Ison because
of that thing that happened ten or so
years ago but that'll be some huge
reveal later I guess it makes the
mystical look normal
this seems made up so that Tyson could
have two eyes and they could save on the
special effects budget strain makeover
alert it just happens to be a mystical
cab that takes mystical people places
how do you turn a profit running this
kind of business to best boys this whole
scene is one of the most obnoxious
things ever put the film I'm gonna go
ahead and give it five sins oh no you
did you
you say you're gonna make it till it
last wine it now we know why there's a
mystical cab out of nowhere in this
story they have important prophecy
information crucial to the plot what do
you know about the prophecy didn't you
get the prophecy from the Oracle herself
what more information could they
possibly have I think we're in Olympus
hail to you great Zeus look the guy who
just rattled this off the fleece is
guarded by Polyphemus captured Odysseus
lives in Circe land it's not mistaken
Washington DC for Olympus extra shot of
nectar you mean there are mystical
creatures everywhere just hanging out
working at coffee shops
how did growver know that this girl was
one of them when she obviously didn't
know that he was one of them these guys
are just waiting for Percy and crew in
Washington DC what do they have some
sort of demigod GPS or something did
they know who the cab would randomly
take them here and drop them off we saw
Luke used this earlier but it seems a
terribly useful device that could
transport them anywhere they want to go
at any time later we find out they're
sailing to the Sea of Monsters why not
just transport their Rover so Luke just
happens to be looking for the exact same
Golden Fleece Annabeth randomly
researched on her iPad lucky for Luke
Annabeth figured this completely random
thing out because how else would he have
been able to kidnap a satyr to help him
find the fleece well we don't know where
yes I know someone who does I know
someone who does cliche also this person
is located in Washington DC and he's
just a short walk away amazing oh man
they drank porn nathan fillion into this
didn't they you twist the cap off this
you release the winds for the four
corners of the earth
so they accidentally came to DC Grover
just happens to get kidnapped while
they're in DC even though they never
plan to go there Luke's dad is in DC at
the UPS Store and he just happens to
have some magic plot device in his
warehouse awesome Luke's on a yacht
called the Andromeda it's passing by
Chesapeake Beach as we speak you mean
Luke is at this minute close enough to
track down imagine the odds Krissi
reaches Chesapeake Beach and they just
happened to see Luke's yacht floating by
in the distance that's it
that's Luke's yeah I can tell because I
spent so many summers on Luke's yacht
that I can spot it from a distance
so does Poseidon Noah hippocampus based
in the DC area or did make this thing
magically appear because you could have
made a magically appear closer you know
sometimes you just gotta ask this never
gets resolved by the way we'd never find
out why Poseidon hates Percy so much
coming oh god yes oh you meant the
journey I forget what I said
oblivious demigod bad guys are oblivious
to other demigods in their presence and
no one's on the luckdragon a pro
during their vessel a minute ago either
she just happens to be and take a look
at this random travelers mode so that we
can see that they have the remains of
Kronos oh you're just now smelling the
intruders like you couldn't smell them
before they went up the stairs right to
seder well you should be in the Sea of
Monsters right about now I sent him on
ahead of some friends you sent him ahead
with some friends I had what why aren't
you going with them
are you going there anyway well it's so
important for you to be on the yacht
right now also you can get a private jet
to fly closer to the Sea of Monsters and
it said you just sailed the entire way
down there you obviously have the means
so why don't you do that
not to mention the magical transporting
thing wasn't easy to find I had to crawl
through the depths of Tartarus itself
then Cleveland
that's hilarious that explains so much
and it's amazing how American centric
these Greek gods continue to be in this
series bad guys hung Annabeth's backpack
nearby for no particular reason instead
of just throwing it overboard or keeping
it in a safe place really you can't use
his water superpowers to bring that
engine back up or have Percy do it
really we were told that this Hercules
wind power thing called winds from the
four corners of the earth making it
sound like the super impressive powerful
thing but it appears as though this is
its only real use shouldn't he be
blowing this yacht away right now does
he have a choice and how slow this
magical Hercules wind thermos works
the Cyclops killed her everyone else in
the world would have just said a cyclops
killed Thalia instead of playing the
pronoun game I should have used two
hands or you could go on your dad to
throw it back or use Percy's water
powers to get it back or call Aquaman
since he's not busy what is this stuff
Prometheus they prefer dead Confederate
sailors whose lives have been given in
tribute to Ares but zombies is fine then
why did all these other zombie dicks
look up like Annabeth just said the
wrong thing you should watch really
oh you don't forget Clarisse talks in
sentence fragments so that Percy has to
ask what the hell she means by that
instead of being able to read Greek I
can see map lines something that was
never brought up until now but plot 30
31 75 12 hey those are the numbers the
taxi lady said that's fortunate
let go of my hand both of your hands
we're gripping the windshield just
before this stupid remark how did girl
forget this disguise and I guess
Cyclopes are supposed to be dumb and
half blind but can he not see the other
two eyes that are obviously sticking out
from under the fake eye this is too dumb
to be true you can smell the half blonds
and you can see them at a distance but
you couldn't smell or notice the
freaking satyr just because he put on
disguise yeah she's dead Hey geez she
didn't break one bone or go unconscious
or anything those demands how did he
know this was propping up the boulder no
matter what convenient Boulder is
convenient for sure movie steals the
villain gets there right after the item
is acquired thing from Indiana Jones oh
sure sure
meets dead I mean unless you're five you
believe that and speaking of Indiana
Jones here's the Raiders of the Lost Ark
finale waiting to happen - the roller
coaster this is the exact same thing
people tied to posts large mysterious
crate guy who's told an important item
from the main character and I'd say this
is darn near the same thing
Lord grown us Hugh was betrayed by his
sons does this really require a ceremony
also why does bring the fleece on the
crate ring Chronos back to life wouldn't
have to put it on his actual remains
damn it did they leave him with his
weapon the water it healed me but not
all the way yet so that we can see the
final touches of the healing on screen
these assholes hung it out while the
battle rages and Luke hasn't even been
subdued or beaten up or defeated yet not
to mention pull off the fucking flees
before Chronos comes back to life he
rises unnecessary explanations these
guys went to the Prometheus school
running away from things the problem
with this monster is that he lunches for
victims in slow motion got off the slow
motion you might kill some fools well
don't just stand there dude keep
swinging your sword obviously works so
what are you staring at Chronos for you
want to know who gave me this sword No
just start swinging it into his flesh
are you waiting for
why doesn't he just throw Percy Jackson
down to the ground like he scored a
game-winning touchdown in the Super Bowl
right now Grover is surely dead from
this fall how did everyone here blank on
the monster that just got up and was
about to stab Annabeth in the back how
did you miss that anyway a good thing
they got that police huh
well I think you should be the one who
gets to do the honors instead of just
throwing the fleece on the tree
immediately they had to go back into
camp show everyone they had the fleece
and then figure out who was best suited
to put the police on the tree this
animal tree could have died in that time
finally you have a destiny is all I like
finding out you have a half-brother
who's a cyclops
might not be as bad as you think it was
pretty bad wait she grew as a tree all
this time but still grew into a teenager
while petrified in the ground good out
of here come on come on helper the chick
has a tree growing out of her how in the
world do you simply pull her out of the
ground like this maybe the Oracle meant
Thalia all along what are you aware that
you're in a movie trying to get another
sequel or something no well the Oracle
did not mean Dahlia a whole prophecy
pointed to events that happened in this
movie also they left this crate out in
the open that's worse than giving it the
parallax treatment so why is it glowing
if Kronos had the ability to come back
to life without the fleece all along why
didn't he just do that and why did this
remains father going back into the crate
in the first place
only Zeus I've confused the depths of
Tartarus itself then Cleveland
you will know vengeance the conventions
to Josh dole ride you tell me
you come wrath
don't worry keep your eyes shut
you seem happy you're happy I hate that
certain flower or whiff of smoke and
bring up experiences long-forgotten if
it's the last and the getting of
knowledge should be tangible it should
be smelly can I get uh four venti
half-caf no-whip lattes and an extra
shot of nectar